so I kind of figured out my issue here
the issue is that for whatever reason
and that other comp it became
disconnected so there's an actual bug in
my project file I did everything the
exact same on a fresh file and it's
working now so that's that is a problem
in and of itself going back to the
optical flares that you were having if I
go to the output now because it wasn't a
3d layer it's gonna be replicated in not
only did I find two full sets of
throwing knives but I also found a
throwing star
this is the real you can't miss wait
some hi miss okay
Where's Waldo find Waldo also if you
like cuz you guys know all this Waldo is
it no there's what no no you tricked me
this I I hate you because this is so
smart there's a Mario in a toad just
randomly in there - oh you're getting
married there's so much happy it's a
very interesting thing is when you do
make something where the video is
everything around you you have to figure
out how to fill the void come like a
giant way in the distance have you seen
that face swap app yes okay so now in
Teletubbies how the baby is like the Sun
the Sun is in four out of five of those
shots and we're just really shocking in
like goopy things for people to find get
you in the mood here we go ready
keep going move back over to your left
all right six new throwing knives in the
throwing stir
well I can't miss here we go come on
come on run
not this one again it would have stuck
work not for the fact that there wasn't
a wall there then just start with it Oh
psych it went through the wall and hit
the other side
I had a grip on it and then it slipped
it into the wall it's gonna have to wait
till Monday I the only reason why I'm
working this hard to get this done is so
that you can do some design on Monday
so you're gonna have to wait till
halfway through Monday so Brad why don't
the effects don't we want to add a bunch
of stuff to the video which is why we
have the green screen set up yes how do
you feel about being in some of these
shots oh my gosh I get to be in another
quarter video I mean in the background
oh okay
I don't make your lies a lot more
difficult but could you is there any way
laying confuse Travolta in like one of
the shots in the video
hey little guy oh my god I hate you run
away from me I'm getting on my knees for
you I can't move it come here come to
your future dead sabe Oh buddy
it's Moby Hugh it's your shirt man sorry
hello my god
it's released why does this man messes
up all your the cutest little thing yeah
I'm back in ninja camp guys feedback I
know how and though we'll find out this
is like horizon and you are a giant man
so do you want my hands to come up and
then over yeah
No hey comment want to hear about my
Lego idea